[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road to 2000 as always my name is caleb
denby
and tonight i want to take you through
uh
some methods for spotting tactics in
your games now why is this so important
uh in your chess games well uh i think a
lot of players
at pretty much every level uh are
generally
able to solve tactics puzzles at a level
a little bit above their rating now
there's some exceptions some people just
can't do tactics puzzles they're just
not good at them um
but for the most part everybody uh
whatever rating level you're at you tend
to be able to solve tactics puzzles
that are a little bit uh above your
rating and
why is that well it's because it's only
really half of the process
to playing a tactic in a game when you
do a tactics puzzle you actually have a
huge advantage
over when tactics are appearing in your
games and that is
you know that it's a puzzle you know
that there's a correct move to find
and you know that you should be thinking
about finding a tactic
so this class tonight is about bridging
that other
uh other half of the process knowing
when
you should be looking for a tactic
knowing when you can spot one
and uh where they're working in your
games
so to do this i want to go over a bunch
of rapid games that i played recently
and maybe we'll go over a rapid game at
a little bit of a higher level as well
with some really interesting games being
played at the magnus carlson
invitational
this year but to start with let's jump
into this game that i played on lee
chess uh my username
is the llama lord my opponent is d4
knight f6 bishop g5 one hyphen zero
so uh true to the username my opponent
did in fact play
d4 knight f6 bishop g5 but then not true
to the username
it was not 1-0 so the game continued
surprisingly i thought i would have had
to resign after
white's second move but turns out
leeches did let me play
another move so i played d5 and so far
we have a pretty calm opening
nothing too much goes on i play c5
attacking the center
white goes for a more conservative kind
of setup almost like a london system
except the bishop is here on g5 see
bishop d3
castles and now f4 uh and
i'm sort of blowing past this because
it's not the main point of the class but
i played b6 knight gf3 and the point of
my opening
uh was delaying the development of this
b8 knight
so that i can trade off white's good
bishop here on d3
so these pieces get traded and white
castles and so so far so good no real
tactics
to be had in this game but if you're the
player with the white pieces
there is already something you should
sort of be taking
note of if you are actively looking for
tactics in your games
so i'm interested to see what the chat
room has to say here it's a very vague
question
but i think someone might be able to
come up with an answer if you're playing
with the white pieces
what has black done that you should take
note of
and keep track of for later in the game
so far
all right i think people are still
filtering in
so i'm just going to give it away it's
this knight on a6
and this is the core of what i want to
talk about tonight
generally there are a few things you
need to look for
in your games to know when a tactic
might arise
and this is sort of the first thing it's
loose pieces
so this knight on a6 is a loose piece
what does that mean
well it means that the knight is either
not defended well enough
or not defended at all now for the
moment the knight isn't attacked so it's
not just a hanging piece
but it is loose and what happens is if
you have one or more loose pieces
sometimes the moves that can attack your
loose pieces
will be able to win material and this is
a
a great way to find tactics both in
tactics puzzles when you already know
that there's a tactic
but also in your games it's even more
helpful
because if you start realizing hey my
opponent has a lot of pieces
that are underdefended or not defended
at all
maybe i have some way to attack them so
so far
this net on a6 is really the only loose
piece so no major tactics yet
but still something important to keep an
eye on
i actually played the move b5 in the
game here
trying to expand on the queen's side my
opponent played knight e5
uh challenging some light squares i
played queen c7
my opponent played queen f3 and started
launching a king side attack
and i continue out now with b4
my opponent plays kind of a strange king
h1 uh we get take
take or ab8 and now g4
so this brings me actually
surprisingly kind of already to the next
thing i want to talk about here it seems
as if
that white hasn't done too much wrong
but the position is already sort of ripe
for tactics
so i'm interested if the chat room can
find a good move for black here
that might already lead to an advantage
what do we think a good move for black
it's not really a trick question sort of
the most intuitive move
is correct here but there's a kind of a
deep deep reason for it
kind of a deeper reason
so black to move here
what do we think
yeah so tim has the right idea you just
go rook b2
and this doesn't look like much of a
tactic yet but notably
it is attacking the loose piece in
white's position
and this is something that you
definitely want to keep track of here
notably
all the tactics are going to revolve
around pieces that are sort of
vulnerable to attack
in some way now that might sort of seem
like
you know redundant like of course the
tactics are going to involve
the pieces that you can attack but
really notably
it all starts with attacking a knight
which just has
no defenders and that's where all these
tactics are going to start arising
my opponent plays rook f2 to defend the
knight
but at this point thanks to the tempo i
gained on this knight
the knight is actually still loose here
and there's actually a few other loose
pieces in the position
uh that are sort of loose by a different
definition
than what i first gave so yes this
knight is loose because it's under
defended it's attacked once and only
defended once that means if i attack it
just one more time
it will be a threat my opponent has to
respond to but there are other ways to
sort of make these tempo threats
and attack quote unquote loose pieces so
i'm also going to claim
that this rook on f2 is loose here
now why is that it does seem to be well
defended it's defended once and attacked
zero times
but because it's a piece worth five
points and
other pieces on the chessboard are worth
less than that
uh it is still sort of susceptible to
getting attacked if this rook is
attacked
by for example a knight it's going to be
a threat that white has to respond to
and thirdly in the position there is
another
uh sort of reason why the position is
ripe
for a tactic here and this is the third
thing i want to talk about i wanted to
do this game first because it sort of
has
everything i want to talk about a piece
that is just
loose a piece that is vulnerable to
attack
by a piece of lesser value and a p
a couple pieces set up for a common
tactical
motif so we have all these things
bouncing around in the position and for
those reasons
there is a winning quote-unquote move
here
that does allow black to get some
advantage so
black to move in the position anthony
has a great idea
in the move knight e4 if there is going
to be a tactical win here
knight e4 is likely it um i actually
played c takes d4 first in the game
which doesn't actually spoil anything
because if my opponent
tries to trade off first i'm just sort
of careening through the position
and winning but c takes d4 first my
opponent plays c takes d4
and then as advertised knight e4 comes
into the
comes into the position now what did uh
trading first really get me well my
queen has a little bit better access
into the game now
but of course the line doesn't end so
white to move and try to survive here
white can actually do a pretty good job
of not just losing out right
and i should mention i highlighted these
two pieces
for pieces that are vulnerable to a
common tactical motif
and of course that motif is the idea of
f6 this is the point of knight e4 here
with knight e4 i make a threat to the
knight
i make a threat to the slightly loose
piece on f2
and i also threatened to play f6
forking these two pieces and that is how
tactics
can arise my phone my opponent did find
a good response though in knight takes
e4 this is really the only move
if you try to play something like bishop
takes e7
you can take this rook with check and
take the bishop and be up in exchange
and if you just defend well i guess
there's really no other move to defend
because the rook is just going to be
hanging regardless so
now i take c4 only move d takes c4 and
my opponent plays queen
to g3 and now here i
actually had an improvement in the game
that i did not
find i simply took the rook
on f2 satisfied in my tactic with queen
takes f2
and f6 but my opponent actually finds a
pretty nice inner meso here
uh sebastian says bishop 792 queen e2
attacks the knights so that's why
um after bishop e7 in this line we're
not taking the knight we're just taking
the rook with check
and then taking here
so yeah of course bishop takes e7 is the
nice move
that my opponent found in the game now
what's the point of this
well the point is i also had a few
loose and vulnerable pieces in my own
territory and so my opponent is sort of
launching counter tactics here this
bishop was a bit loose only defended
once
of course this rook is literally hanging
in the position
and this rook on f8 is also sort of
vulnerable to
attack and there's actually no real way
out of this one
for me here i can play a move like rick
takes h2 and go up a pawn
in the game i actually just played rook
c2
and the game continued from here after
bishop f8 king f8
now uh with these tactics black didn't
actually win any material
but black still does have a good
position here because of the control
over the c
file and the openness around uh around
this white game now i went on to win
this game
but that's not super relevant this is
the really relevant part of the game
that i want to talk about here starting
with rook b2
so rook b2 rook f2 i think it would be
really easy for a lot of people to
instantly play a move
like rook b8 here just like rook fb8
say yeah my position looks pretty good
i'm just going to keep invading
maybe i'll take here and try to invade
on the b file as well
but really importantly this is a
position right for tactics
and the alarm bells that should be going
off are sort of realizing hey
all these pieces are sort of loose to a
94 idea
and these pieces are sort of vulnerable
to a common
tactical motif so
way as far back as here you can be
imagining hey if i ever move my knight
with tempo
i'm gonna get this move f6 and i'll be
able to win a piece
now it doesn't work immediately but
we'll see this idea come into play
of course right here and so that's what
spotting tactics in your games
is all about it's about being aware of
pieces that are vulnerable to tactics
even if the tactic doesn't work
immediately
when the pieces kind of find the right
combination of uh
of things to do then that's when your
tactics appear
so that was my first example that i
wanted to go over
and my tactic didn't even work in this
game the point though
is is that i spotted a position that was
ripe for tactics
and that is what we are trying to train
now in this position after queen h4
black is actually already winning again
with the move f6
because the knight is in a trap
but i actually missed this one so just
to show you nobody's perfect
my tactic didn't even work and then i
missed the winning tactic
did go on to win the game though so
questions on this introductory
tactic here uh with rook b2 can you take
h2 so yeah rick takes h2 would have been
winning upon their
exquisite corpse with um
just an extra pawn but uh honestly i
prefer the other line
because now i am not in in control of
the c file i thought that was a bit more
relevant and that's why i played rook c2
uh okay
let us move along to our next example
then it's going to be yet another
rapid game for me and the reason why i
am showing you guys a lot of rapid games
because i think this is the absolute
best way
uh to sort of train your
intuition for these kinds of tactics
because when you play a really long
time control game over the board you can
sort of just brute force it by like
trying to calculate out to find a tactic
on every turn
but what's going to end up happening is
you're going to spend a lot of time
trying to find tactics in positions
where there just aren't any
and you're you're going to run out of
time pretty quickly
you're also going to run out of energy
pretty quickly so it's important to
develop the sort of intuition for when a
tactic might appear
in the position so let's sort of flip
through this game and see if we can spot
any potential tactics along the way
in this one i started with d4 we get a
queen's gambit
exchange variation bishop g5 c6 e3
bishop out to f5 now and queen f3 and we
play this sort of funny line
uh knight ge2 knight a6 knight g3
and potential tactics in the position
chat room what do you think are there
already
some potential ideas to be aware of
so far i would argue there aren't really
any loose pieces
but there are a couple really important
common tactical motifs that we should be
keeping in mind
some really important tactical motifs
that we should already be keeping in
mind
all right karna fascina says they see
nothing and that's because there's no
tactic in the position but there are
tactical motifs
that you need to be aware of that's the
point i'm trying to get across here
you don't need to calculate out to find
a tactic but you do need to be
aware of sort of potential threats
potential tactics and that's what we
have here there's actually one for each
side
with the white pieces i need to be at
least a little bit wary
of this move knight b4 because it
threatens to jump in with knight c2 and
a very common tactical motif
forking the king in the rook with the
the typical knight fork
and now as the player with the black
pieces i actually need to be a little
bit worried about this bishop
why is that well whenever you see a
bishop stuck in front
of its own pawns like this it's going to
be a little bit vulnerable to getting
trapped so moves like h4 h5
could be a potential threat for white
even f4 f5 could be a potential threat
for white
now i don't know if these are going to
be relevant in the position yet i don't
know if
i can use any of these tactical ideas to
win the game
but i'm keeping them in mind right you
got to keep these in mind
and say hey wait a second can i combine
one of these ideas with something else
maybe not yet
but in the future my opponent actually
plays knight b4 directly
which is of course just a wrong move um
it makes the threat of a tactic
but one move threats can sort of be
parried here and king d2
is just a good move for white so it's
important to understand what i'm saying
be aware of this tactic that this
tactical idea exists
i don't mean you should go for this
tactic you should like try to make this
tactic happen
right away very often that's wrong but
for example
if i were to play some sort of bad move
here
and i'm trying to figure out how i can
even make knight b4 be a relevant tactic
maybe i can't but if knight b4 could
somehow
make a secondary threat at the same time
then i could run
into some danger that's the idea okay
so night before king d2 played in the
game my opponent plays a5 now
and in a sense use this tactic use this
tactical threat
uh to gain a tempo to play the move a5
now in the game uh i actually make the
same mistake as my opponent
and i play the move f4 uh kind of just
making a one move threat
my opponent plays h5 of course to give
the bishop this square
i play h4 to cement this pawn onto the
h5 square
my opponent plays bishop d6 and i want
to pause again
and see if you guys can spot any
potential ideas
in this position already here there are
some things you should be wary of
once again
so what should you be aware of in this
position are there potential tactics
are there potential tactics here chat
room
and yeah amos actually already has a
great
tactic so with the white pieces here we
actually have a number
of loose or undefended pieces this
knight on g3
is sort of it is undefended it's not
attacked so it's a loose piece
and believe it or not we can actually
consider uh sort of these pawns
to be loose pieces as well this pawn on
f4 is only defended once and it is in
fact attacked once
so if something happens to this e3 pawn
then
uh we're gonna be in trouble and in fact
here
i played the move a3 and this just turns
out to be a blunder black does have a
winning tactic
and it's the tactic that uh almost
pointed out here
knight c2 taking taking advantage of a
common tactical motif
attacking my loose rook on a1 and then
after the rook moves
we're going to get knight takes d4
bishop takes f4
and it's going to be a rough time with
the white pieces here the knight is
simply hanging on g3
and we have another common tactical
motif so
that's where these tactics are coming
from it's really important to realize
that uh whenever you make loose pieces
like this you know the
the age-old saying loose pieces drop off
does have some basis in reality
and after bishop d6 a3 my opponent
actually didn't find the move knight c2
and this is what i mean when i say
players can solve tactics puzzles
well above their rating level but when
they find when it actually happens in a
real game
very often they just get missed if you
gave this position to my opponent
and said black to move and win without a
doubt i'm
quite confident they would be able to
find knight c2
and knight takes d4 bishop takes f4 but
if you give this position to my opponent
in a game and play a3
very often knight a6 gets played without
thinking
and that's what happens here and now
neither player realizes
how dangerous white's position actually
was and the game
just continues so again the point i'm
trying to get across here
in your games you should be looking for
tactics revolving around
the loose pieces you don't need to be
hardcore calculating on every turn
but when these common motifs and loose
pieces
start to add up we have something like
four pieces vulnerable to attack in
white's position
that's when the tactic that's when the
tactics start to arise
and when they could have arisen for my
opponent here now we're going to fast
forward a little bit
i played bishop d3 just getting
developed knight e2
and slowly but surely started to
actually defend my pieces
uh i think i get outplayed a little bit
though my opponent
captures a pawn for free this though
isn't really a tactic
just sort of a blunder by white it's a
rapid game it happens
uh this net ng3 also ends up falling
but at the end of the day uh
i find some activity none of this is
super important we're getting to the
important
parts and now i want to talk about
another type of threat that we actually
haven't touched on yet so we're going to
look at a wide variety of ways tactics
can arise
and a wide variety of things you want to
look out for so
white to move here in this position i
play the move h5
and this is not a tactic of course this
isn't a tactic this is just pus
pushing uh upon in the end game right
past pawns must be pushed
but the advanced pawn is actually
another uh tactical idea
that you need to be aware of so we have
these common tactical motifs these forks
these pins
uh double attacks things of that nature
we have this idea
of attacking loose pieces and now the
idea of an advanced pawn is actually
another way to threaten to win material
rather than capture material you just
threaten to make another queen
and win material that way so by playing
h5
already you should start be you should
start thinking about tactics
with both sides here uh with black you
need to be thinking all right
do i have some way to stop this pawn can
my opponent do some funny
threat with the rook and then queen do i
need to be worried about this
you know and this is when you should
start calculating
and with white of course you're just
doing the exact same thing
but in reverse you're thinking what can
i do with this rook how do i get this
pawn promoted
and can i use this pawn to deliver any
tactics
now in the game my opponent plays the
move f5
trying to bring the king over to stop
the pawn
but already uh white to move
and win there is a tactic in the
position
wait to move here
who sees it
a tool says rook h6 okay what's the idea
what's the idea of rook h6 rookie 8
and h6 that's another one okay
so you guys are along the right track
and this is where
actually being able to solve tactics
puzzles does come and
come in handy of course that's another
useful skill that you want to train
but the point i'm trying to get across
is this is a position
where you should be thinking about
tactics
uh now in the game i was thinking about
tactics but i actually missed the
correct move here as
is most of the chat here so rook h6
doesn't actually
do a whole lot for you here i think um
just f6 by black is is probably good
enough and you're actually in
in your own pawns way it's going to be
tough to get this guy promoted
and uh what were the other moves um
king f4 seems highly illegal knight f4
also seems highly elite okay
knight f4 seems good but um
yeah rookie 8 check uh is another
interesting idea but the black king is
actually just going to step
closer to the pawn now rook c8 is what i
played in the game
but here it turns out king d7 is good
enough for black for the moment
turns out the winning idea is pushing
the pawn forward who would have guessed
that your passive pawns
must be pushed uh this is the only move
uh that actually wins the game here and
what's the point
well the point is after king c8 our king
f6 now you go rook c8
and this pawn is indefensible if you go
knight e7
then h7 and you can win the game
um so why is rook c8
uh worse well after rook c8 we don't
have to go 97
we can actually go king king d7 to
defend this pawn
and then if we try the same thing knight
f6 is in time to catch the pawn
uh so rick c8 king d7 played in the game
and i actually stepped back with rook
h8 and my opponent played king e7 and
then i played h6
uh and after king f6 we transposed back
to the main line of the actual tactics
so a little bit of back and forth there
but after king f6
we're back to this line h7
and queens and now white is simply up a
piece
so let's sort of take stock of of what
we have
in mind here so so far let's jump back
to the initial tactic that my opponent
missed after a3
here my opponent has a tactic and it's
important to understand
that these tactics don't come out of
nowhere my opponent has a tactic because
i made a lot of loose pieces right
all of these pieces are somewhat
involved in the actual tactic
and they're all sort of under-defended
so does this mean you should never make
a loose piece ever in your game
no this means that if you do make a
loose piece
or if your opponent makes a loose piece
that's when you need to start thinking
about these tactics start making sure
that nothing bad is going to happen to
you or
try to make sure that you can make
something bad happen to your opponent
so again knight c2 the idea here with
knight takes d4
and bishop takes f4 just being
unstoppable
and then later on we have this idea
of the advanced pawn being used in
tactics as well
so we're building up these sort of
warning signs loose pieces common
tactical motifs
and now the advanced pawn is also really
important
now i want to introduce yet another idea
that is going to lead to tactics and
that is the idea of the weak
king and for this one i'm going to turn
to players a little bit better than me
to show off just how complex tactics can
be
but how they are sort of made up of all
these same building blocks that we're
just talking about
and for these players i am turning to
one grandmaster
wesley so against one grand master ali
reza
for ruja of course they just played in
the magnus carlson invitational
and this is probably uh the wildest game
in the tournament definitely the wildest
one that i've seen so far
it was a lot of fun so let's take a look
here we have wesley with the white
pieces
starting off with the keralan get bishop
f5 knight f3
e6 bishop b2 this is actually the short
variation i myself
like going c5 here ali reza chooses the
slightly slow
slower move of knight e7 preparing this
break a little bit more
and actually he goes for some expansion
on the king side with h6 g5
in the meanwhile wesley soap pushes an a
pawn because that's what alpha zero does
and alpha zero is very smart
a6 by black b4 now by wesley
and wesley just gains a ton of space
over here on the queen side
and now this is likely the downside to
taking your time with playing the move
c5 you
might not ever get the chance if you're
playing leslie so
so instead ferisa starts pushing on the
king's side with f6 now
this stuff isn't really that tactical uh
kind of play
that i wanted to talk about here uh
wesley pushes f7
just to get rid of the king's castling
rights and after we finish development
here knight bd2 bishop d6
knight b3 um
i want to pause here for just a moment
and just take stock of the position
so if you were to look at the loose and
vulnerable pieces here
you might think that this bishop on d6
is a bit loose because it is
undefended for the moment and while that
is true it's also a very difficult piece
to attack right there's really only one
legal way to do it
and that would lose a bishop for white
so not super
dangerous for black to have this bishop
here and for white i am going to claim
there is
actually a sort of vulnerable piece uh
in the form of the knight on
f3 it's defended well enough but it is a
bit vulnerable
to a pawn push which could start
unleashing some tactics
for black now in the game black actually
plays the move queen c7
and keeping in mind our idea of tactics
now the pawn on h2 is a little bit loose
and of course
black has made the threat of g4 now this
might seem sort of obvious to people
but it's important to understand that uh
these components of like loose pieces
still exist in these positions farrugia
is making this threat
uh to play a tactic with g4 so he's
noticing
that this knight is vulnerable and now
trying to take advantage of it
while at the same time making a useful
developing move that's how these tactics
are getting used at a high level wesley
of course spots the threat
and plays the move g3 but importantly
black has sort of developed the queen
for free and that's how you can start to
make use
of vulnerable pieces even if you don't
directly have a winning tactic
we get knight f6 by ferruja bringing the
knight into the potential attack
bishop d3 by wesley is offering a trade
and now we do just get g4 gaining space
for
ferruga and the knight steps back to e1
and now h5 we get rook a2
and now h4 and uh
at this point i think this is a good a
good time to sort of stop
and say uh let's reevaluate
the loose pieces and see if this is a
position where black may have
black or white may have a tactic so with
h4
has black made a threat chat room what
do you think
did h4 make a threat here
what's up manny thanks for coming out
and yeah exquisite corpse in the chat
says it's the short variation
wrong variation i don't know if he means
by white or by black but
i tend to agree
manny has apparently seen the game i
guess this one was pretty famous
was a pretty famous one so uh
jaden says i'm a trust farouza and say
yes and that's
not really a bad way to uh to go here
so with h4 uh on the surface level
if we're just talking about material h
takes g
f takes g bishop takes pawn takes
queen takes it looks as though white is
not losing any material
but of course this is ignoring the huge
factor of king safety
so in fact the king safety is what is
really going to be relevant
in this game and in fact is is what uh
almost decided the game
in both players uh favor instead of
course they ended up drawing
so uh this is the next building block
that i wanted to introduce
uh the idea of king safety so we have
these loose pieces these common tactical
motifs
and now king safety is going to be
really really important because of
course
you know having a weak king it's kind of
like just having a loose piece if the
king
except if the king dies you know there's
no uh coming back from that no counter
tactics
so in the game wesley plays the move
knight c5
which is correct now why is the move
knight c5 correct
honestly it's it's a little bit above my
head i think the point
is that if you do go in for this
variation now
queen g3 rook g2 queen
h4 the point now
is that uh well number one
uh white is going to be able to make
some counter threats using
using this knight on c5 and number two
let's just see what happens
for example if i were to play a bad move
i like rookie two
why does this make a difference
hold on i didn't get into all these
variations when i
started here okay there's knight takes
f4 here all right just trust me knight
c5
is correct and we're not worried about
the details of the tactics this time
we're worried about the tactical ideas
behind them
and so now black plays the move rook h5
so let's try and see if we can find the
move
that wesley so missed now okay ignoring
these random sacrifices that nobody has
time to calculate
let's see if we can find the move that
wesley stowe missed in the game
using these sorts of tactical building
blocks
that we're talking about first of all
why might there be a tactic here in the
position
well because this piece is looking a
little bit loose here
on h5 it's only defended by the knight
this piece on g4 and
sorry not on g4 this piece on f5 and h5
is perhaps vulnerable to a potential
fork
on g4 and of course the king on f7
is not the safest it's ever been and
because of all this
there is in fact a winning tactic here
for wesley so so see if you guys can
find it
[Music]
bishop takes bishop on f5 i'm not sure i
agree
so yeah shove actually has the right
idea the highly counterintuitive move f3
you know your opponent is attacking the
g3 pawn a billion times
so what do you do well of course you
undefend it that's just the way it goes
and the point now is that if your
opponent does capture on g3
we actually do have our super common
tactic of forking
bishop and rook taking advantage of the
king weakness
a common tactical motif of a pin and uh
as well as just launching an attack
against the black king
after something like g2 you're gonna get
some complicated stuff here
involving the king coming out to f2 but
at the end of the day
this fork is going to be nasty and if
you want to take here
you can take on h5 and have a winning
inner meso with h takes g6
so f3 would have been a really nice find
for
uh wesley but understandably he he
missed this one
and the point i'm really trying to get
at here is that
uh your tactical play will will really
be at a much higher level
if you know when to think about tactics
in this position
it kind of seems obvious that you should
be thinking about tactics
but knowing where to look is also going
to be very helpful noticing the rook
opposite the king
these common pinning ideas noticing
these pieces
sort of ripe to be forked that's how you
can start arriving at moves like f3
in your own games even though wesley
missed it here and played rookie too
so rookie two and now ferrugia decides
it's go time
takes on g3 takes on g3 takes on g3
and gets queen to h3
now wesley so starts playing a series of
very interesting moves that's uh lose
the game
but do make it quite interesting so with
this knight on c5
wesley's big idea is to sacrifice on e6
now
why sacrifice on e6 here i think the
idea
is to soften up both the f file along
with
this d3 g6 diagonal attacking this
knight here
on g6 so we get bishop takes e6 in the
game
and now knight f3 was wesley's idea the
point being
uh the threats on this diagonal are
actually going to be useful
and this knight is going to come in to
help attack as well
but of course black to move
does ferrugia have a tactic
a counter-tactic
exquisite corpse has a tactical saying
cct
plow checks captures threats pawn moves
loose or overworked pieces that's a lot
that's quite the acronym
quite the acronym there
so yeah this is the question exquisite
corpse it's less about
what you do when you're calculating and
when you're calculating
you want to find out when the position
is right for tactics
this one it's a bit more obvious that
it's right for tactics
because you know that everything's just
so crazy in this case most of the
tactics revolve around this
king's weakness and yeah everybody seems
to know
already that um queen takes g2 is the
idea here
uh i don't know if i could have come up
with this one on my own
but queen takes g2 does win the game and
the point now
is that after g takes on f3 there's
simply no good way
to recapture this guy if you play rook
takes and get hit with knight takes or
knight h4 check
and knight takes on f3
and something like rook h3 here there's
just really nothing good you can do
with all of these ideas coming into the
position
of course queen takes f3 immediately
would lose to knight h4 check winning
the queen and king takes f3 loses to
this common tactical motif of the skewer
so
farrugia could have combined all of
these tactical ideas
uh forks pins skewers and
a weak king to to win the game here with
something like this by the way
if you just play something like king f2
black
might not have a queen here but black
does have
plenty of opportunity to continue
attacking this king
and that's sort of the way the game
would have gone something like rook f8
and
black is just continuing with with a
winning attack
okay but queen takes g2 was missed in
the game by the way queen h1
followed by queen g2 is the same instead
farrugia plays the move knight h4
which does look like a pretty good move
right you just bring another piece into
the attack
but now wesley simply trades this piece
off goes bishop
f4 guarding the h2 square a little bit
and also giving the king a slightly
better
flight path than he had before we get
rook h8
by ferrugia queen e2 and now
everybody agrees that the game is a draw
um
after g3 wesley does have to take this
pawn to give the king this flight path
once again
now we get queen h3 and believe it or
not
there may be a tactic here for wesley
once again
so white to move
why is there a tactic
magician auriga i don't remember which
chess player was called the magician of
riga to be honest with you
all right my producer ben simon says it
was tall
i don't maybe it could be i believe it
yeah it was tal ben simon knows more
about chess history than i do
it's tough
yeah in the times i think we're we're
pretty accurate i think this is about
how much time they had
but okay what is the tactic of course
not rook takes f6 no reason to sacrifice
the rook just bishop e5
and this is just the start of a a
winning attack now
for white of course this can be defended
but um actually fuji defended it the
other way
which also works but now after
rook takes f6 check rick takes f6 the
ship takes f6
we get a queen check by black and now
of course king takes here would simply
get checkmated
to something like this so king takes
bishop not going to be playable instead
foruger goes all in with rook h2
but white does actually have a way to
win the game here
with the amazing move bishop g6 check
the king
cannot really capture here because then
this is a fork
uh so king f8 would be forced and simply
queen f3 now or really any move
and uh ferrugia is not going to get away
with it
instead wesley unfortunately misses this
bishop g6 idea
and they trade pieces and agree to a
draw
so quite the game here between furuja
and wesley so in a highly tactical game
and the point i want to get across from
this one is just highlighting
how important the king safety can be in
a relatively normal position
way way way back it looked kind of
relatively normal
i would argue that this one might look
abnormal to most people still
but it's nothing really too crazy you
have this weird-looking king
on f7 but you know both sides have sort
of their space on each side of the board
it's not as if there's a ton of tactics
in the position so how does ferugia go
about creating tactics
well he does so by attacking the king
one of the most common ways to end up
with a super tactical game
is like this so when do you start
calculating tactics well you start
calculating the tactics when you can
start making tangible threats
and those happen against the loose
pieces those happens those happen with
common tactical motifs
those happen with a weak king they
happen with an advanced pawn
you just sort of start building all
these things together to develop an
intuition
for when you need to calculate all right
questions on this game i know we didn't
delve
too deeply into all the variations there
this is more of a broader
broader picture type of class tonight
but questions on this one before we keep
moving on
keep moving on
yes or as exquisite corpse says just use
this very simple acronym
with seven letters okay let's move along
then i want to step back
to uh sort of the realm that i
understand which is my own 10 minute
rapid games because again i do think
these
rapid games are a great way to train
sort of tactical intuition
um because you know in a real
over-the-board game
you do have enough time to calculate a
lot more
but it's really really helpful if you
can sort of fall back on that intuition
to give you these alarm bells when you
should be thinking of tactics
and in 10 minute games when you can't
really calculate everything
you sort of have to rely on that
intuition a little bit more
okay my opponent was a 2300 by the name
of spiroz
and i had the black pieces we get a caro
khan just like ferrugia
except my opponent plays the fantasy
variation instead
d takes e4 is the main line you get e5
knight f3
bishop g4 bishop c4 all very normal
stuff so far
knight d7 uh by the way
even though this is just the opening and
i do just know all the theory here i
think
my opponent and i both did this is
already a position
where you should be thinking about
tactics and you should really be
thinking about tactics if you don't know
the theory here
so who can spot some common tactical
motifs already
in this position
are threats being made yet
so yeah of course of course of course
there are tactics in the position
this pawn is uh attacked and not even
defended
this bishop is undefended out here on g4
and my king is a little bit weak right
and so of course
white is actually making a threat here
of bishop f7
in knight e5 when uh white would just be
winning the game so i i did sort of just
already know that this tactic existed
here because it's only move six
but notably even in the opening these
things can appear when you start making
loose pieces so that's why knight d7 was
played
now if 95 is tried i can play knight
takes e5 and defend the bishop
so instead we get castles knight gf6 and
the same problem exists now with the
knight defending e5
so h3 was played i went ahead and
captured on f3
and played bishop d6 so
uh after the move c3
uh i'll go one more move ahead i castled
white plays bishop g5
should i be thinking about tactics here
and if so
what tactics should i be thinking about
what tactics what tactical ideas are in
the position
what pieces should i be looking at fork
on e5 yeah this is an important one
this is an important one got to look out
for a potential fork on e5
and uh this is a little bit more of a
positional concept but
that's why we're sort of building up
this strong point on e5 for black to try
and
prevent something like that happening so
yeah there's a common pin
in the position and that pin is on this
diagonal we can pin the pawn to the king
and actually take advantage of simply
two loose pieces
this is what happens when there are
loose pieces this is where tactics
sort of come from and so it's never a
bad idea
uh to just sort of stop and and start
thinking
what pieces are loose in the position
and can i just like attack two of them
at the same time
the simplest kinds of tactics are
sometimes most often
most often missed because you just don't
stop to think about them
right and that's what happens in this
position i actually just sort of play h6
without thinking
um or i just as well could have played
something like queen c7 without thinking
just trying to develop but in reality
there's just a very simple tactic here
right if you give this to somebody as a
tactics puzzle they're gonna say queen
v6 attacking two things at the same time
but if you give this uh if you don't
give it to them as a tactics puzzle if
they just are playing a chess game
more often than not i would say well
maybe not more often than not
but very commonly it's just going to be
missed because
players aren't thinking about tactics
yet they're just trying to finish
development
and that's the idea i'm trying to hammer
home you should only think
well you should think about tactics
whenever you are spotting
loose pieces in the position both of
these bishops are also loose here now
that didn't actually contribute to any
concrete tactics here
but it just as well could have and it's
important to notice
so h6 in the game and my opponent backs
up
still could go queen v6 here and start
taking free stuff
instead i played queen c7 my opponent
played knight d2
i just expanded out with b5 bishop b3
and c5 uh and now my opponent plays
queen g3 and this time around
my intuition was strong enough to to
spot the tactic here so of course
common tactical motif is the discovered
attack
and this one is simple enough for me to
find
and so after this the game actually
ended pretty pretty quickly here my
opponent played queen f2
and i think we might be able to spot
another common tactical motif
after queen f2 what do you think
chatroom
what do you think here any tactical
ideas
g5 oh my god i didn't see g5 to be
honest with you
i guess this bishop's trapped something
a bit better a bit safer than g5
pin queen to king that's exactly right
so my opponent
has placed the king and the queen in an
awkward position
susceptible to a common tactical motif
of a pin
and so noticing this just noticing
awkward arrangements of pieces
allows us to start finding tactics like
uh i think i played c4 first
can also play d takes c3 bishop d1
and d takes c3 just gaining tempo
and now making another threat in the
game my opponent actually just
recaptured
i played bishop c5 and my opponent
resigned so
that's how you end up with an 18 move
game now obviously my opponent
helped me out a lot here by blundering
some pretty simple tactics
but even before that just simple stuff
like queen b6
if you start paying attention to loose
pieces in your games it's going to be a
lot easier
to spot the simple stuff just look for
the loose pieces look for common
tactical motifs
and don't i'm not saying you have to
treat every position as if it was
a as if it were a tactics puzzle i'm
just saying if you keep an eye
on these things the tactics sort of
start to make a little bit more sense
they don't come out of nowhere
they come from the loose pieces all
right we've got a few minutes left i
want to do
just one more with you guys and this one
is actually going to be
more of a calculation test i guess uh
i'm tired of showing all these games
that i won
it's time to show you one where i got
crushed um so
let's do that with someone named
erfang han i ca i can't i don't know why
i try with lee chess names
i can't even pronounce real names much
less leeches names
so it's going to be another character
and actually another kero khan fantasy
variation
we get knight f3 bishop g4 this time my
opponent tries taking on e5
and we get this sort of simplified
position here
h3 take take knight e5 regaining the
pawn
um f4 knight g6 and
uh so far so good right uh nothing too
crazy in the opening the d file got
opened
the queens got traded we get king e2 uh
knight f6 and now king to f3
so are there any tactical ideas
lurking in this position chat any
tactical ideas
that i should be aware of here
exclusive corp says the lesson is that
everyone hangs things and online rapid
and yeah that's that's part of what i'm
trying to get at here like
i don't mean to brag but i think most of
the viewers aren't
rated stuff like you know 24 70 or even
2300 like the previous opponent
and it's important to realize that it's
not some crazy high level of chess we're
playing here we're still missing tactics
all the time
and doing these simple things these
simple checks where you're just like
wait
is there a tactic here like is is my
opponent
making a ton of loose pieces those
simple things simple changes to your
thought process can be really really
helpful
in gaining kind of a lot of rating
potential fork on f2 or h4
i don't like i guess this is the fork i
don't know what we're talking about here
knight takes c2 is an idea if we can get
there
so of course with queens off the board
uh you all should be playing for
checkmate what's wrong with you why
aren't you playing for checkmate here
this king is weak
white is underdeveloped and i have two
attackers against zero defenders
uh in front of this king of course also
this pawn
on e4 is a little bit loose and that is
going to be helpful
to our cause as well so with that hint
here
we're playing for checkmate with black
believe it or not
and combining the idea of checkmate with
the idea that this pawn is a little bit
weak
if uh if white isn't careful
and yeah sebastian has the right idea so
it all starts with knight h4 check here
and the point is
that if the king runs this way it's
going to get checked again and even
checked again if it tries to defend this
pawn
and eventually you got to give this one
up and black is
much much better and if you try coming
the other way
so defending the pawn via tactical means
you're actually going to get checkmated
here
you're going to get checkmated buddy of
course black to move in this position
everybody sees the idea
who knows the idea here
so not quite h5 because that would allow
our opponent to play something like
f5 get this bishop in the game to help
defend but of course our idea is going
to be
f5 ourself keeping our opponents pieces
locked out of the game the only try
for white is to go rook g1
we still just give check and now h6 and
you're you're gonna get checkmated quite
simply i guess
it's technically not checkmate if you
run this way but of course black is
winning here
um up in exchange up quite a few pawns
and this king is not super happy on the
g6 square
so surprisingly in this position after
king f3
black already has a winning tactic and
that tactic is
to go after the weak king and go after
the loose pieces in the position
that's where all these tactics are
coming from now i actually missed this
in the game because i'm not a super
genius and
i also didn't think i had any chance of
checkmating the white king
with queens off the board so i just
played bishop e7
and from here i started playing some
very bad moves and ended up losing the
game so
h5 by my opponent is not necessarily a
tactic
but it's setting white up to be able to
to have tactics in the very near future
now why is that well first of all this
knight has no good squares to go to
so it has to go to e7 and already you
just sort of
start feeling a little bit nervous right
this knight looks very loose
on e7 it is defended by the bishop for
the moment but the bishop is also sort
of floating out here
the bishop is loose there's common uh
pinning ideas on the diagonal
and in fact that is sort of what happens
in this game i play bishop takes c3
which is a very bad move i make more
loose pieces
and then it all sort of starts falling
apart here with
uh my opponent's two bishops being a bit
too
a bit too powerful here with these pawns
coming down the board
and we don't need to look at the rest of
this game i i tried some sort of clever
checking
on the way out but my knights ended up
just getting getting a bit trapped
and i lost this game pretty convincingly
but i didn't have to there was this big
tactic in the opening
um okay so let's wrap it up here
i'm gonna take questions from the chat
on this game or any of the games overall
that we talked about
and then i just sort of want to say you
know my my final piece
on trying to spot tactics in your own
games so questions from the chat first
um i don't think there is going to be
too many this one
was a bit more of a straightforward
tactic than anything else
so let's wrap it up here so what did we
learn tonight well
uh the the preface is that
you know players are very good at
solving tactics and tactics puzzles
they're a lot less good at
finding tactics in their games they
don't know when you should be looking
for a tactic
and that is how most tactics end up
getting missed if you stop and say hey
look there's a tactic here
more often than not people can can
actually find it
so what do you look for well you look
for loose pieces
you look for common tactical motifs
things like the advanced pawn
things like a weak king a king that can
be attacked
and if all of these elements are sort of
fumbling around in the position
that's when you really need to stop and
say hey wait a second
there might be a tactic here and with
that simple
sort of thought process that sets off
these alarm bells for you
you'll get a lot better at splatting
tactics in your games
just take it from wesley so and farrugia
anyways that's going to do it for us
here tonight on the road 2000 as always
i want to thank you guys
very much for watching uh tune in
later tonight on the twitch channel it
looks like harrison is going to be
doing another late night show twitch.tv
st louis chess club
um and do you tune into that please tune
in next week for another road 2000 and
as always
i will see you next time
you